oi boa noite
há 8 boa noite e é por isso que eu vim
falar para vocês sobre mim e mostrar o
meu dia a dia porque não existe regra
para sucesso mas muitas pessoas me
perguntam com isso o que fazer
a rua complicações
o mestre mitchel tem que falar o seu
olhar o banho do seu negócio usar o
melhor do que miguel tem que se ligar
ladies fashion night goes on
bom humor humor comédia casa comediante
o comediante ela acho que é o cara que
só faz comédia
tá ligado humorista eu já acho que é o
cara que mexe com a emoção por exemplo
eu acho que no meu show eu gosto daquele
momento da luz 30 uma música tá ligado
que eu quero que a galera queria uma
atenção e fale nossa que massa essa
música todo mundo fica ali do lado mas
se tu me chamaram que vai cortar vocês
não vão mais calma tu vai ser vai ser a
última a última depois ajeitei ajeitei
uma pessoa que eu sempre coloquei muita
fé né é eu acho que tem que ter mais
mulheres comediantes é só jogar o
colocar qualquer pessoa para poder fazer
tem que ser uma pessoa que esteja
disposta a fazer essas um engano sabe
essas coisas assim que todo mundo tem
vergonha de fazer depois que as pessoas
pergunta que a dancinha e aquelas coisas
que eu falo com o cara me deu essas
coisas aqui ó
e agora olha vai ficar até 3:00 da manhã
em cima do quarto da gente cara querendo
dormir ele uma chegar pela rua está
transando desse gato esse universo de tá
aqui na casa do whindersson morando
praticamente na casa do whindersson
durante mais de 15 dias mergulhado na
comédia gente respira comédia acorda
falando de comédia easy dias na casa
doença eu respirei comédia eu comi
comédia
e cadê a comadre falou porque muita
besteira muito legal é recebeu o tom o
tom já assistiu o cara que tu teve como
referência a vida toda referência de
comédia fazer a personagem para fazer de
cara limpa fazer tudo cara é genial e
ele tá lá te dando um feedback do teu
short assistindo assim a 2m de distância
é inscreverem dado finale foi super
legal foi do camarim conversar com a
gente ficou legal bem bom menino também
quando você tá fazendo coisa que não faz
isso viu
e para criar você tentar tem que dar uma
vibe de inspiração primeiro mas você
chegar na frente do computador pegar um
papel e querer escrever que nós sair
[ __ ] nenhuma entendeu você conhece
várias pessoas que tu faz cirurgia no
coração é minha irmã tem uma cerveja no
coração tá ligado agora no cu eu não
conheço gente não esquece o carro é
operada do lixo não é uma hemorróida é
do lado né na bunda e no culpa é do lado
dinho assim dá buraco do culto entendeu
não quer ir eu acho que era tudo bem eu
tô bem tô bem tudo certinho tudo não não
teve problema nenhum ó
o wi-fi e
e aí